latest weather event brought strong
winds and lots of dust to our area but
it also drops some high elevation snow
sally jaramillo joins us live now
outside of mount charleston and sally it
was definitely quite a sight right
christian a beautiful winter wonderland
up here in our local mountains and while
technically it's still fall this
activity isn't uncommon
monday night we received our first
measurable snowfall of the year the base
of lee canyon got seven inches and areas
higher got about nine crews were out
cleaning the roads today while it's
beautiful lee canyon officials want to
remind everyone they're close to winter
sports right now they're asking people
to wait until the weekend to come up you
can still see the shrubs and everything
popping through so you know people
looking to snow play there's still a lot
of ground up you know like below the
resort there's still a lot of ground
obstacles so i would definitely um
kind of discourage that uh as far as
like sledding or any you know any
activities running around in the snow
just be careful celie added seven to
nine inches isn't enough for skiing or
snowboarding it's a long process to get
the trails ready for that activity and
while snowfall like this is exciting we
still have a long ways to go
out here live if you plan on visiting
this weekend a reminder please dress
according to the weather and now for a
closer look at our snow totals let's
send it over to ted florendo all right